what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and on the videos about the
young code the warlords and the Marines
I've been getting a lot of requests to
do a video about the worst generation
and here it is if you enjoyed these one
piece of videos and want to keep them
coming best thing you can do is smash
that like button and share this video
with a friend if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one piece videos I've
already set up a playlist of one piece
videos that you can check out I do make
videos that you guys request so drop a
suggestion in the comment and it may be
the next one piece of video you see
before we jump into it I want to give a
quick thank you to raid Shadow legends
for sponsoring this video with YouTube
ad rates plummeting as a result of the
global health crisis sponsors like raid
provide independent channels like this
one with much needed support and we
really appreciate it rain shadow Legends
is a turn-based RPG that I have been
personally playing for over a year and I
find it to be an extremely fun way to
pass the time especially now that so
many of us have a lot of extra time on
our hands rain shadow legends is free to
play and you can now play on both mobile
and PC I love the action and strategy in
this game and the daily log in rewards
program has just been doubled from 90 to
180 days every day you log in you can
claim new free rewards everything from
energy refills to free silver and gems
and now you can even claim a free
barbarian legendary champion cylinder
Drake's try it out for yourself for free
just click the link in the description
if you're new to the game you can now
claim an extra 200k and silver and a
free champion Grinner just look at this
absolute mad lad if you start playing
within the next 30 days you will find
your extra rewards here in your inbox
just click the link in the description
to get started there will be manga
spoilers in this video you've been
warned now without further ado let's
jump into it brown beard explains the
worst generation to us he says that the
entire group that was at saborío Capel
ago two years ago is known to the world
as the worst generation meaning the 11
supernovas that we'll get into and the
uncle Blackbeard they are known as
problem children born in the gap between
the end of one age and
beginning of another faded to bring
chaos wherever they go after the war at
marine Ford the worst generation spilled
into the new world wreaking havoc
everywhere they went brown beard says
that at the center of every shocking
incident or calamity you'll find one of
the worst generation pirates
that's a mighty epic introduction to
these super rookies and it definitely
hyped me up the first time I read it the
11 supernovas all come from nine rookie
crews every pirate captain is included
along with two non captains namely
killer and Zorro who also have bounties
over 100million berries currently the
twelve members of the worst generation
collectively have a bounty of at least
six billion 727 million six hundred
thousand that's more than even the king
of the Pirates gol D Roger had when he
was alive which gives you a sense of how
much of a threat these super rookies
pose big news Morgan's even said that in
the near future one of the worst
generation will become the next Pirate
King so now that you're hopefully hyped
up about the group as a whole let's
start looking at the supernovas
individually keep in mind since I
covered Blackbeard in my all five
Emperor's explained video and in my all
eleven warlords explained video I'll
just be talking about the 11 supernovas
here check out those other videos if you
want to see a breakdown of Blackbeard
specifically first up let's look at the
currently 23 year old Eustace Kidd aka
Captain Kidd the captain of the Kidd
pirates Kidd had an even higher bounty
than Luffy did ATSA Bodie his old bounty
was 350 million berries and his current
one is 470 million berries Kidd is much
more of a bad boy than Luffy and we're
told that the reason his bounty was
initially higher is because his crew
slaughters and pillages innocent people
he's one of the most fearless guys
you'll meet he destroyed two ships that
belong to big mobs allies and according
to him injured one of her sweet
commanders while taking what he meant to
take before that says Kidd he lost his
arm in a battle against the red-haired
pirates aka shanks his crew he got
beaten up and captured by Kaido like
Luffy did however like Luffy he wasn't
scared off he's now formed Alliance with
Luffy and law and they're going to
attack Idol who's currently allied with
Big Ma so yeah this dude has already
clashed with Rhian Co in one way or a
another and he keeps coming back for
more you've got to respect that he
possesses a bell fruit that has not been
named but it seems to be associated with
magnetism he can attract and repel
metallic objects including swords and
rifles he's able to repel a cannonball
and send it back at the shooter he also
uses this ability to create a giant
metal arm that he can use in battle the
drawback is that if there aren't any
metallic objects around then Captain
Kidd's powers wouldn't be very useful
however it's uncommon to come across
opponents who don't carry around some
sort of weapon that kid can make use of
and even if his surroundings don't
include any metallic materials he can
always use his powers in conjunction
with the weapons he carries which
include a pistol and a dagger and his
mechanical arm Kidd is the only known
member of the worst generation besides
Luffy who's a confirmed conquerors
hockey user it stands to reason that he
should be able to use the other more
common forms of hockey as well including
observation hockey and armament haki
next let's look at Captain Kidd's
crewmate the twenty seven-year-old
killer his post times get bounty is 200
million Barry's killer was much more
calm and level-headed before the Wando
ark he was often contrasted to his much
more impulsive captain however he was
fed a defective smile fruit by the beast
pirates as a result he didn't gain any
cool animal powers but rather just
smiles and laughs uncontrollably even
when he wants to cry according to kid
killer used to hate the way he laughed
when someone made fun of him for his
life he would beat them half to death
that's why he ended up covering his face
with a mask
however the defective smile fruit
changed him for a while he worked as an
assassin for Orochi and was known as
commas oh the man Slayer but he was
discarded after he failed to kill taco
when Captain Kidd escaped from jail he
took killer with him so he might be
present in the fight against Cato in the
past killer cut through Marines with no
problem and his power must be great
because he managed to get such a high
bounty without being a captain and
without having devil fruit powers he can
still fight but he did lose to Zorro in
mono he usually fights with scythe like
weapons and blades pre time skipped
he fought with rotating scythe blades
that were attached to his forearms
against Oro he used regular cites
it really does speak to both killers and
strength that the two were able to
become supernovas without being captains
and without having dealt through powers
since everyone else on this list as
we'll see is a pirate captain and has
devil fruit powers next let's look at
the big eater jewelry Bonnie who is
currently estimated to be 24 years old
she's the captain the Bonnie pirates and
the only female on this list
her last given bounty was 140 million
berries she eats like Luffy and she's a
waifu candidate to boot and although she
can be rude our restaurants she does
have common sense she was nice enough to
stop Zorro from hurting a world noble
which could have caused a lot of trouble
for our favorite swordsman however she
had personal motives as well because as
a pirate she didn't want an admiral to
show up in her view a pirate ring help
people just to help them despite
Bonnie's best efforts Luffy ended up
punching the world noble of the face so
we kind of ended up in the same place
clearly bonnie is more cautious than
Luffy and Zorro she sees Zorro as an
idiot and Luffy has an even bigger idiot
and promises that she'll kick their
butts if she ever sees them in the New
World
obviously she couldn't but it's the
thought that counts later Bonnie gets
caught by Blackbeard
strength-wise Blackbeard calls her a
weakling but he recognizes her waifu
potential and asks her to be his woman
she responds by hitting him and calling
him a bearded swine when a kind who
shows up Blackbeard his men leave a kind
who tells Bonnie that a cold shiver ran
through his spine when he heard she ran
away from the government we're not sure
yet what he meant by his mysterious
words whether she was just a special
prisoner or whether she was actually a
marine or some important world
government official now let's talk about
her double fruit it appears to be a
paramecia fruit that lets her manipulate
her own age or other people's age in
other words she can turn her enemies
into harmless toddlers or into elders
because of her ability we also can't be
completely sure about how old she is
even though she appears to be 24 she
could potentially be much older
interestingly enough as an old lady she
appeared at the reverie as Queen Dowager
of sorbet Kingdom she cries when she
sees kuma who was the former king of the
sorbet Kingdom being used and mistreated
as a mindless slave by the world Nobles
so she clearly has a significant
connection to kuma and might truly be
related to sorbet Kingdom royalty
next we have the
currently 31 year-old scratch men a pool
AKA roar of the sea he's a music themed
pirate and his crew is called the on-air
pirates
he went from a bounty of 198 million to
a bounty of 350 million during the time
skip he started working for the young
coke I know he's a deceitful guy and he
feigned cooperation with Kidd and
Hawkins when he was actually planning to
turn them over to Kaito Appu has a music
based devil fruit that lets him turn his
body parts into instruments he can then
create music using his piano teeth arm
saxophone and entrancing rap voice the
music creates sound waves that can
injure his opponents his music cuts Keys
on who and then caused him to explode
although the Admiral recovers using his
logia powers the Admiral overpowered
Appu easily enough but Appu survives the
encounter we haven't seen him use his
powers a lot but he's clearly a force to
be reckoned with since he has such a
high bounty along with Beast pirates
support next let's look at the 47 year
old Rouge the mad monk he is a pirate
from sky island and he is the captain of
the fallen monk pirates before the time
skipped we know that he had a bounty of
108 million berries but it should
definitely be higher now in fact he beat
one of big mom's sweet commanders
Charlotte Snack who had a bounty of 600
million he did however lose the sweet
commander charlotte cracker who has a
bounty of 860 million but he managed to
survive an escape who ruched in way
better than I expected him to you
clearly can't always trust bounties
because will Rouge had the lowest one
from the worst generation but he
obviously did amazingly well despite
that his devil fruit powers awesome - it
converts damage into strength his body
and muscles grow and his attacks become
much stronger he was able to punch
around a pacifist APRI time-skip
at that time he was no match for admiral
Kaiser who combined with the pacifist
those lasers but we have every reason to
believe that he's gotten stronger over
the past two years
just like Luffy and the straw hats did
rouges enhanced revenge counter punches
are called karmic punishment in the VIS
manga which is a pretty dope attack
named not gonna lie the other epic thing
about him is that his weapon of choice
seems to be a giant freaking pillar this
guy's strong yet and I look forward to
seeing more of him
future don't sleep on Rouge let's look
at the currently 33 year old red flag
x-drake next his bounty was 222 million
berries before the time skip Drake is a
former Rear Admiral of the Marines and
current captain of the Drake pirates
Drake is associated with the Beast
pirates and is one of the flying six aka
one of the six strongest headliners in
kylos crew secretly it seems like he's
still working for the Marines as captain
of the top-secret special force called
sword we can see Oda's love of history
coming into play here the historic Sir
Francis Drake was a privateer he was a
hero and vice admiral for England but
also a pirate in the view of the Spanish
it seems like extra is similarly loyal
to his government even as he acts like a
pirate because Drake knows so much about
the Marines and can potentially get help
from the Marines when he needs it he's
all the more of a big player in the
world of one piece he fights with a
sword in one hand and a four-sided axe
in the other and I didn't even know for
sudden axes existed he can easily stop a
fight between two different supernovas
like a Rouge and killer let's get to his
also interesting devil fruit he ate on
you do you know me model Allosaurus it's
an ancient zone type fruit that lets him
transform into a dinosaur and Allosaurus
to be specific these dinosaurs were
carnivorous and at the top of their food
chain they picked on those other
vegetarian dinosaurs and Allosaurus
could reach a length of 39 feet in his
dinosaur form Drake can make a pacifist
a bleed which is impressive since
they're made out of a material stronger
than steel he can also turn into a
hybrid form like most zone users this
half human half dinosaur form looks
pretty epic I must say Drake can use
hockey which allowed him to easily
defeat the logia user caribou next let's
look at the current 31 year old basil
Hawkins
he's a magician and fortune teller with
a bounty of 320 million berries he's the
captain of the Hawkins pirate and he
decided to join Kaido when he was
betrayed by a poo he's currently one of
the headliners his predictions seem to
be accurate enough since he knew that he
and the other supernovas would survive
the confrontation with Admiral kazoo
something that was definitely not
self-evident
he ate the white owada no me
the straw straw fruit he is able to
create and control straw it's a riot
that he'd use his straw powers to fight
the straw hats of all people but he does
he can create scarecrows to fight for
him he can also use voodoo powers so
that the damage he and his straw
creations take can be redirected to
another person usually his own men he
can use his sword that he uses in
conjunction with his straw powers to
create a straw man that is a stand-in
for the lives of his followers as he
explains that Hawkins infuses his body
with the spirits of his subordinates by
using his straw straw powers so that no
damage reaches him thus he and his
creations can die many times and recover
like nothing happened his straw
creations can fire nails at opponents
and Zorro can't even avoid them all
Hawkins has cars that he draws and they
impact the battle they can work for him
or against him one card might make his
own men fight each other law another can
enhance the power of his straw man he is
definitely a skilled fighter when Luffy
and Zorro end up clashing with him in
wanna they manage to escape after a
while but easily taking down Hawkins is
not an option
later Locke clashes with Hawkins for a
bit but also doesn't beat him before
Luffy and Zorro scoop him up even later
though and imprison and handcuffed law
somehow manages to get free and get the
upper hand on Hawkins it is then that
Hawkins reveals that he joined Kaido
because he had a zero percent chance of
beating him or escaping from him how
exactly lostcape if he had see stone
handcuffs on is unclear but it seems
like he got help from someone we did see
X Drake right before the planned
interrogation so it might even be
possible that he secretly intervened to
help law we'll have to wait and see who
helped him and why law goes on to spare
the life of Hawkins so Hawkins is a wild
card right now pun intended he might
stay loyal Tokaido run away or even
somehow try to help his fellow
supernovas since he clearly only joined
cato because he was forced to in the
first place next let's talk about the
now 42 year old Capone gang BJ he's a
Mafia don turned pirate and his most
recently revealed bounty is 350 million
Berry's even higher than Zoro's bounty
and Hawkins bounty he's a captain of the
fire tank pirate
during the time skip Capone married
Charlotte chiffon had a son and began
working on their yong-chol big mom
however with luffy he tries to kill big
bomb they fail and the pirate Don
understandably becomes an enemy of big
mom and her crew capone is a tactical
genius and uses more brains than bronze
to get what he wants he's also very back
here valiant and willing to lie and
cheat in order to carry out his plan his
failure to assassinate big mom was the
first time one of his assassination
plans failed since he's 42 years old
that's still a pretty long track record
of winning and even after this failure
he managed to escape with his people his
aim is amazing he succeeds in hitting
Charlotte oven who's on the shore from a
ship in the sea but not just that he
hits him in the face while avoiding his
wife whom oven has taken hostage now
let's get into his interesting and
unique devil fruit powers Capone ate the
Cheryl she don't know me aka the castle
Castle fruit this fruit lets him have a
dimensional fortress inside his body he
can fit many subordinates in there and
even cannons he can open tiny draw
bridges on his body and then his
subordinates can use them to fire
cannons at the opponents around him once
they get a certain length away from
Capone's body the objects revert to
normal size thus cannon balls will
revert back to normal size and causes
much damage as if someone launched an
actual cannonball at you from close
range
so Capone has the benefit of surprise
and an insane amount of firepower
available wherever whenever
he can also chill inside his own
dimensional fortress body and hold
private meetings with others in it while
his normal body remains in place unmoved
as if that wasn't good enough he can
also turn into a giant castle with
superior defenses then he can control
the castles parts and weapons as if he
were a giant mecha I liked Luffy and
chopper think this is extremely cool
he's used many different types of
weapons like a pistol tommy gun and even
the KX launcher invented by caesar clown
he also possesses a sea stone spear that
he can use against other devil fruit
users clearly his intelligence
preparation and versatile devil fruit
powers make him worthy of being a worst
generation
next let's look at the twenty
six-year-old trafalgar de water law AKA
the surgeon of death he's the captain
and doctor of the heart pirates in a
very cool dude with a very high bounty
his bounty is currently five hundred
million berries among the supernovas his
bounty is only second to luffy's he even
became a warlord during the time skip
but it was revoked when he teamed up
with luffy and helped him take down
doflamingo he possesses the Opa Opa know
me aka the op op fruit he can create a
sphere around him and as smoker points
out everyone inside the sphere is a
helpless patient on laws operating table
he reigns supreme within that space and
is able to spatially manipulate what's
in it in the space he can do stuff like
effortlessly split ships in half split
people in half stop bullets take
people's hearts and so on he has
telekinetic like powers that let him
move objects or teleport them by
switching the locations of different
objects with each other you can also
create electrical surges like a
defibrillator and those shocks can be
strong enough to take that opponent the
op op route user can perform a
personality switching surgery which
allows him to swap people's souls and in
the hands of a skilled enough user the
fruit can apparently give eternal life
through the immortality operation the
user would lose their life though after
giving someone else eternal life because
of this it's been called the ultimate
devil fruit after the time-skip laws
ability covers a much larger area
suggesting that the area of his matrix
room will continue to grow as he matures
the fruit is perfect for a doctor since
it can be used to cure illnesses he can
practically extract anything from the
human body and law used it to cure
himself of the amber lead poisoning
inside his body which was originally
supposed to kill him by the age of 13 in
addition to his awesome devil fruit law
is a skilled swordsman and he often uses
his sword in conjunction with his devil
fruit powers he also possesses armament
haki and observation haki now we finally
come to our straw hat supernovas let's
start with our 21 year old pirate hunter
Zorro his bounty is currently 320
million berries he has a higher bounty
than multiple worst generation pirate
captains and those pirate captains have
devil fruit powers while Zorro doesn't
as we know his goal is to be the
greatest swords
in the world he's also known for his
unique three sword style where he holds
a third sword with his mouth
Zorro has gotten a lot stronger over the
course of the story and especially after
the time skipped during the time skip he
trained with the current strongest
swordsman in the world me Hawk at this
point he can cut through giant ships
with ease he can cut through pacifist Oz
which are harder than steel and he can
even use haki to beat logia users like
Monett you know though Sanji's new
bounty of 330 million berries surpasses
Oro's I don't think Sanji will ever
surpass aural and strength after all
Zorro is arguably the character that
we've seen training the most over the
years and he wants to be the greatest
swordsman while Sanji's end goal is more
associated with cooking rather than
fighting Zorro is without a doubt one of
the characters that's inspired me the
most over the years his level of
endurance bravery and manliness is
incredible he willingly chose to absorb
all of the pain and fatigue that luffy
had accumulated during the thriller bark
arc in order to save him kuma told him
that since Sorrell was already close to
death before absorbing the pain taking
in luffy's pain would kill him but
sorrow did it anyways
not only did Soros survive he even
stayed conscious long enough to tell a
worid Sanji that nothing happened as far
as epic role models go it doesn't get
any better than Zorro lastly we have the
19 year old Luffy the captain of the
straw hat pirates his current bounty is
the highest of all supernovas at one
point five billion Berry's although I
think it was a premature call Goofy's
accomplishments led to the newspapers
dubbing him the fifth Emperor of the sea
usually yong-chol can clash on
relatively equal ground with each other
as we saw when shanks and white beard
clashed and when big mom and Kaito
clashed both times the heavens split
open and all fighters were fine however
Kaito completely wrecked Luffy during
their first encounter after DeWanna war
though Luffy might deserve to be called
an emperor we'll have to wait and see
along with him luffy's crew has many
formidable members with high bounties
like Jim Bay who has a bounty of 438
million Jim Bay's bounty is
significantly higher than the bounties
of most supernovas Luffy is also the
head of the straw hat grand fleet which
includes 5,600 people in total Luffy
self has also upset the balance of the
three great world powers the yong-chol
the warlords and the Marines by beating
three warlords namely crocodile Moria
and Oh flamingo ex warlord Jim Bay has
joined his crew and ex warlord Law
allied with him as of now the system of
warlords has been disbanded altogether
Luffy's that is Revolutionary Army
leader monkey dee dragon who's
considered to be the world's worst
criminal and Luffy's close friend is
yong-chol shanks the man who stopped a
paramount war this list of Luffy's
impressive connections goes on but i
think you get the idea
luffy is connected to a lot of extremely
strong people and he's extremely strong
himself notably luffy was strong enough
to bring down category the sweet
commander with the highest bounty over 1
billion berries as we know now luffy is
working on taking down the yonk owe
themselves let's look at Luffy's velop
fruit the global gone with no me a cave
the gumgum fruit the fruit turns luffy
into a rubber man he is able to stretch
turn into a bouncy balloon and
significantly neutralized the power of
blunt attacks he often uses his rubber
qualities in battle to enhance his
offensive and defensive abilities then
there are luffy's gear forms second gear
takes advantage of luffy's rubber blood
vessels expanding them and allowing more
oxygen and nutrients to be pumped
throughout his body his skin turns pink
and his speed and attack is drastically
increased after the time-skip he can use
this ability with select body parts and
the side effects have been reduced third
gear takes advantage of luffy's ability
to inflate his bones for example he can
use his ability to make his arm huge
which drastically increases his attack
power even when compared to second gear
as with second gear the side effects
have been reduced while third gears
effectiveness has increased
thanks to Luffy's use of armament haki
fourth gear was created during the time
skip luffy blows into his body making
his upper body muscles much more
pronounced the ability relies on hockey
since luffy covers his body with
armament haki this gear increases his
attack defense and speed significantly
there are different versions of it like
bounce man tank man and snake man tank
man is much bigger and increases defense
while snake man is much thinner and
Pryor
Taizo speed and offense since gear 4 is
so powerful it makes sense that there
are side effects Luffy can only maintain
gear 4 for around 20 minutes after that
he is unable to use any hockey for
around 10 minutes because he needs to
wait for it to recharge understandably
using gear for a lot can have a huge
toll on Luffy's body Luffy is also one
of the few people who can use conquerors
haki
conqueror haki users are said to possess
the qualities of a king and can exert
their own willpower over others as we've
seen Luffy can use this ability to
defeat a huge number of weaker world
people without even fighting them
physically he also possesses the
mysterious D in his name and as we know
characters with D in their names like
pirate king gol D Roger are usually
powerful individuals who are often
considered to be an extreme threat to
celestial dragons and their world order
and that is it for today's video thank
you so much for watching this video took
quite a long time to finish so if you
did enjoy I'd appreciate if you could
drop a like and share this video with a
friend it would mean a lot if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future want peace videos we already
have videos on the yong-chol warlords
admirals and now supernovas so let me
know what video you would like to see
next in the comments thanks again and
until next time see you space cowboy
[Music]